جدلون كبير على مواقع التواصل اثرته قصه
خطوبه بلوجر رهف الشامي من زوج صديقتها
المقربه القصه بدات عندما نشرت الزوجه
السابقه سلمى عبر حسابها على موقع فيسبوك
تدويره قالت فيها انها اكتشفت خيانه
البلوجر لها قالت سلمى انها تفاجات بصور
خطبه زوجها لصديقتها المفضله رهف الشامي
الامر الذي اصابها بالصدمه مشيره الى ان
صديقتها اشترطت على زوجها تطليقها كي
توافق على الخطبه على الجانب الاخر دافعت
رهف عن نفسها في عده منشورات وقالت ان
خطيبها الحالي انا خطيبها قبل عشر سنوات
وانها زوجته السابقه وضعت مكائد حتى اوقعت
بينهما وتزوجته هي وعلى مواقع التواصل
انتشرت القصه بشكل كبير فيما حذر النساء
من فخ الصديقه المقربه ومدى احتماليه وهو
الزوج في شباكها
[موسيقى]
من مصر سالنا السيدات بكل صراحه هل تخشين
على زوجك من صديقاتك المقربات
[موسيقى]
دلوقتي
ومش عارف ايه وكل ده وفجاه في يوم وليله
تقلب عليك عشان خاطر جوزك يعني انطق صحابي
بس لا الصراحه كامله لا ما هم اصحابي وهو
جوزي لسبب لان انا اصلا واثقه فيهم هم
الاثنين فان انا لو انا مش واثقه فيه ما
كنتش ما كانوش دول هيكونوا اصحابي اولادها
هيكون جوزي هو المفروض ان انا صاحبهم على
اساس ان انا واثقه فيهم نفس ان انا يعني
على جوزي كده وبرده واثقه في جوزي يعني
اكيد
في واحده بس انا متاكده عشره عمري انما
مثلا ما يبقاش صحابي البنات الثانيين
العاديين ويجيء بتجيء واحده فيهم تقعد
جنبه وتقعد تهزر معه وابقى قاعده عادي
يعني مش كيس جوافه ههه
[موسيقى]
ينضم او تنضم الينا من الشرقيه ليال ابو
فرحه مرشده العلاقات
الزوج بصديقات زوجته المفروض
صباح الخير صباح النور
عنا ثقه
في زوجي اكون عندي ثقه في صديقتي ولكن
لازم يكون اشخاص متوازنين في علاقاتنا
العلاقات الانسانيه ضروريه جدا في حياتنا
وبين الافراد لكن
فينا نقول
تربينا بالاخلاق انه للبيوت
اذا كان دائما بتعاملوا على اساسيات وحفظ
الاسرار اذا دخلت انا هذا البيت
بتكون العلاقات المتوازنه
طيب ليال
يعني ليال ليش دائما بنسمع قصص دراميه عن
غدر الصديقات لا نسمع يعني رجل غدر بصديقه
تزوج مرته هل هذا موجود الطبع في الاناث
ما بعرف يمكن اختلاف من رجل لرجل بس بين
الصديقات اكثر بس الفكره مش انه رجل او
صديقه هي احترام خصوصيه لازم كل شخص يكون
عنده توازن اذا بدي ارجع يعني اؤكد على
اكثر من شغله احترام الاحترام ويكون في
توازن في العلاقات لازم يكون في عندي خطوط
حمراء وحدود وهاي الشغلات اصلا بتبلش
ذاتيه يعني قبل ما اكون انا متزوجه او انا
لسه مش متزوجه طيب جميل طيب ما هي الحدود
او ما هي الخطوط الحمراء في تعريف الزوجه
لزوجها عن صديقات
العلاقات والاشخاص عباره عن دواء
الشخصيه دواء الذاتيه دوائر في علاقه
زوجيه ودوائر مع اهلي وكل دائره خاصه مو
معناته انا اليوم اذا كان عندي صديقه
مقربه مقربه لازم كثير افضفض مو لازم
اليوم افتح التليفون احكي كثير اليوم في
مهارات حياتيه ان احنا بنقدر يعني
مارسها في حياتنا اذا كنت متزوجه ولا مش
متزوجه ده انا قدرت اتقن هذه المهارات راح
يكون عندي
هتكون حتى شخصيتي متوازنه وقادره اتعامل
في حدود العمل في حدود الزواج الاقارب في
حدود عائله الزوج يعني وهذا الشيء بدنا
نسقطه كمان على الزوج والزوجه
بين الصديقتين يعني غدر الصديقات ربما
تكون المشكله مثلا بالرجل نفسه بانه هو
مهيا للخطف بان تخطف وامراه يعاني من
ازمات في البيت نقص مثلا يريد ان يعبيه في
مكان اخر
يعني انا بدي هيك السؤال هو كثير حلو بس
خليني اجي اقول لك اذا الرجل في عنده كعب
كثير وفي عندنا مشكله المدخل بيجي عن طريق
الست لان كثير بتفضفض اه ليش ما يصير
مبدا الفضفضه في فرق اني اقول اليوم انا
متضايقه انا تعبانه صار موقف عابر بس من
غير ما اعطي تفاصيل كثير خاصه عن حياتي
ليه اليوم انا صرتي اعتبر انه صاحبتي
مقربه يعني لازم تعرف كل شيء عني هو مش
تخوين في الاصدقاء العلاقات الانسانيه
يعني ضروريه بين الافراد نحن اليوم ما
بنقدر في مجتمعنا من نعزم عائليهان وبين
عندنا عزايم يعني
الفكره في الشخص نفسه شو المهاره اللي هو
بيملكها في حياته وكيف حدوده الشخصيه حتى
لما بدي اكون عندي حدود شخصيه مش ضروري
اكون عدائيه ادرس العدوانيه احط حدود
والناس ما تحبوا شيء لا انا الكل راح
يحبني راح يكون قريبه القريب البعيد لازم
نتحلى بهاي الشخصيه القريبه البعيد انا
موجود معكم ومش موجوده
انا شايفه يعني انه يجب على كل سيده ان
تختار
صديقتها قبل ان تختار زوجها بعنايه يعني
حتى نختم خلصت القول
مش بالضروره لازم بس يكون عنا ذكاء
اجتماعي ووعي وادراك لكل شيء بيدور
حوالينا لانه اكيد في مؤشرات بتكون ظاهره
لكن اللي حوالي انت مش مدركه والرجل كذلك
لانه في خيانات من النساء لازواج لا عن
طريق رجل دخل على البيت على انه صديق جدا
احنا ما بنصف هذا الشيء على المراه فقط او
على الرجل فقط واذا بدنا نرجع للتقرير
والقصه اللي ضخمه ما تعصرش الميديا
الاسقاط على الافراد الثلاثه يعني
المسؤولين عنها
شكرا جزيلا لك تيكس تو تو تانجو من
الشرقيه ليال ابو فرحه مرشده العلاقات
الزوجيه والاسريه شكرا